the first female superhero movie from
Marvel did not disappoint us at all the
long-awaited Captain Marvel movie is
action-packed and full of important
details about the MCU let's unpack the
ending of this epic film would you know
Captain Marvel begins with a memory in
Carol Danvers dream she sees dr. Lawson
played by Annette Bening gets shot by
someone when Carol wakes up we see her
train with Yann raagh a Kree warrior
played by Jude Law Carol is a member of
the Kree fighting group called Star Wars
their mission is to capture a scroll spy
the scroll are a sneaky alien race they
can shape-shift into any form as long as
they see that form first Carol is
kidnapped by Talos the scroll leader
they try to extract her memories with
Lightspeed technology in our memories we
see dr. Lawson and Pegasus Pegasus is in
the early MCU movies it was the
organization dedicated to studying the
tesseract Carol escapes and tracked the
scroll ship to earth she crashed lands
in a blockbuster store talk about a
throwback that's how we know this is
definitely not a modern-day movie Carol
meets Nick Fury an agent of shield Fury
isn't the head of shield just yet he's
also got both of his eyes he doesn't
believe Carol at first but eventually he
realizes that the scroll have invaded
earth star force is on its way to help
and Carol knows that finding out her
lost memories is the key scroll have
infiltrated shield so Fury and Carol are
on their own
Carol's old friend Maria enters the
picture they also meet a cat who is more
than meets the eye
the real enemy Talos tracks Carol in
fury to Maria's house in Louisiana talus
is right-hand man shape-shifts into
Maria and plays with her daughter Monica
we expected a huge fight scene to go
down but what happened next left us
talus apologizes to Fury he explains
that the scroll aren't there to fight
they're just looking for a home the cria
have been set on wiping out the scroll
they're committing genocide on the whole
race dr. Lawson who had creeped ours
knew the truth she was helping the
scroll
Talos tells Carol that she has been
totally
I do she had no idea that she was
helping wipe out an entire race of
aliens just because the Kree hate the
scroll just because their scroll and now
this girl needs a new home there's some
serious social commentary in this
storyline Carol fury and Maria agreed to
help Tallis defeat the Kree this also
makes a lot more sense with what we know
about the Kree from guardians of the
galaxy it were portrayed as vicious
zealots who want to wipe out other
species it turns out that is exactly
what they are who is dr. Lawson there
was a lot of speculation about who
exactly a net benning's character was
going to be we were shocked when we
found out the truth dr. Lawson has been
dead for years when the movie starts
Carol witnessed her death but she can't
remember who shot her a flashback toward
the end of the movie shows us the truth
Carol and dr. Lawson were testing light
speed vehicles together in space they
get chased by Kree and shot down Carol
sees that her friend dr. Lawson has blue
blood dr. Lawson was shot down by yon
raagh Carol's Kree training officer it
was because she was helping the scroll
she had made a whole secret Space
Station for scroll refugees it turns out
that dr. Lawson was the og Captain
Marvel you struggle with your emotions
with your past which feels she was
injected with blue blood which is how
she got her powers Yan raagh takes Carol
to the Kree home planet of hala he
injects her with the blue blood too now
she is the new Captain Marvel with all
these awesome powers but they wipe her
memories and convince her to fight for
them dr. Lawson was using the tesseract
to make Lightspeed vehicles
you probably remember the tesseract from
the first Avengers movie it contained
the space stone which is one of the
Infinity stones it has incredible energy
and was sought after by Loki and other
enemies in Captain Marvel Carol and fury
hide the tesseract in a lunchbox and
then it gets eaten by a cat the cat the
funniest parts of the movie are the
scenes with Nick Fury and the cat well
at least it's a creature that looks like
a cat Dallas is terrified of the
adorable furry pet it's actually an
alien called a Fleur c'n and it's very
dangerous fury doesn't really believe it
but then the cat scratches his eye yep
tough Nick Fury lost his eye from an
alien cat scratch he's probably never
trusted another cat since the floor can
can shoot out tentacles from its mouth
gross you might be wondering how shield
and Pegasus got the tesseract back in
their possession this is where the final
end credits scene comes into play after
all the credits we see fury back at his
desk the cat hops up onto the desk and
starts hacking you think it's about to
cough out a fur ball but instead it
coughs up the tesseract it's hilarious
but it's also super important for the
next movies in the MCU timeline the
pager and the Avengers we first see Nick
Fury's pager at the beginning of the
movie but it's just a regular pager this
was how people contacted each other
before cell phones came along Fury's
pager is how he contacts shield at the
end of the movie
Carol fixes it up with Kree technology
she tells fury to use it if he ever
needs her again it now has the Captain
Marvel symbol on it fury doesn't use
this until the end credits scene of the
infinity wars he manages to get a
message out to Captain Marvel before
he's vaporized by thanasis snaps
sometime later we see Nick Fury with his
eyepatch
he's writing an initiative called prop
Coulson asks if it's true that an alien
shot him in the eye he says he cannot
confirm or deny we wouldn't tell someone
that we lost an eye to a cat either then
Fury sees an old Air Force photo of
Captain Marvel it says caroled the
Avengers Danvers he crosses out the word
prop on its initiative turning it into
the Avengers initiative so he pretty
much named the whole Avengers program
after Carole and game
this second post-credit scene is the one
with the cat and the tesseract but the
first one gives us a hint at avengers
endgame Captain America is watching a
holographic counter of the number of
missing people Natasha and Bruce are
there Rhodey comes in and mentions the
pager he says whatever it was stopped
sending out a signal
Captain America wants to turn it back on
but Bruce says that they don't know who
it is on the other end of it it turns
back on to the Captain Marvel symbol
they turn around and see Carole she says
where's fury
the ending of Captain Marvel explained
we can't wait to see more of her in
Avengers endgame what was your favorite
scene in Captain Marvel let us know in
the comment section thanks for watching
use your superpowers did that subscribe
button for more awesome videos from the
themes see you next time
[Music]